what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 24th of may [__] memorial day
weekend get ready to go listen bikinis
are out
you got your little bathing suits out
you want to look good okay
this [__] joint is brought to you by
manscape and i'll tell you why i did it
this way
because if you need manscape it's this
[__] week
wake the kids call the neighbors tell
them there's a public service
announcement
it's finally here the lawnmower 4.0
ready for the [__] you've been in
seclusion
for 15 months your balls your [__]
must look like [__]
[__] obama's cave whatever his
[__] name is what was the guy
i don't even know bin laden's [__]
caved
there's bats down there you got
dingleberries in your ass hole listen
i ain't mad at you my area doesn't look
that good for a while either
nobody gives a [__] during a pandemic
but it's time
bikini season here summer seasons here
you got to show your [__] unit
if you want to get your [__]
staminkia sucked and the lawnmower 4.0
has the same advanced
ceramic blade and skin safe technology
that you know and love plus
the 4.0 lets you set the length of your
trim
so if you want to shave above your dick
but leave like a little trim around the
circle of your helmet to play with you
you know what i'm saying
you got to trick them from time to time
you adjust the guard size from one
all the way to four you [__] filthy
animals i love it though
and now the spotlight is even better
with the on and off switch
and the 400 of the 4000k led not light
now you can shave your wife's [__] in
the dark tell me that's not a [__]
turn on
plus they got the new travel lock you
can take your ball trimming show
on the road check this [__] out
oh yeah a little wireless [__]
charging who's better than you
get the lawn mower and more with the
ultra smooth package
this is completely different i'm giving
you the crop shaver you know what that
is
i don't know no the crop shaver this is
the average [__] razor
this is a smaller thicker with a micro
cone ball
and three precision blades i'm also
giving you the crop exfoliator
it reduces buildup and ingrown hairs if
you know what i mean you have a smell
down there
it smells like 10 dead milkshakes that's
what it is it's built up
and i'm giving you the crop gel features
four
essential oils it's like a spa treatment
every time you shave your nut sac
and around your dick pole and like i
told you we're introducing the crop
shaver
this isn't your average razor it's
smaller and thicker
with the micro comb and three precision
blades oh my god
wait till you shave your little friend's
[__] you're gonna have a party
if you want to get out there and sling
dick and swing dick
and get your dick sucked and your [__]
eating get the ultra smooth
package and the lawnmower the new
lawnmower 4.0 today
by going to manscape.com
shoei again manscape.com
showy that's 20 off and free worldwide
shipping by going to manscape.com
joey manscape use the right tools
for the [__] job it's time okay
go to manscape.com right now
preston joey
and shaved those [__] ball sacks and
that [__]
dick polio's [__] suckers and now
it's time for the show it's just
manscaped today
i thought it was important
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here it's monday the 24th
that's it memorial day weekend coming up
you [__] are excited
i'm gonna go to the beach during the
week because i know i won't be able to
to go down there next week and see on
the [__] weekends
especially this year people aren't gonna
[__] travel so
like i've been hearing reports about
people paying for houses down the shore
amounts that are [__] rental
properties like uh
jim florentine on his block has a lady
three kids
she said the offer they made her on her
house for june
would take care of her for the summer so
she [__] rented it out
you know people are doing that people
don't want to [__] get on planes and
they just want to stay local but this
week i want to talk to you about
something
because we've all all of us
half ears that are watching this or
listening at home have us
have experienced this at one point or
another in your life you've gotten a job
and you've gone in there
enthusiastically
you really wanted to make this work
and after a few weeks of being there you
get to meet people you get to see
different people what they're doing and
you realize that the guy that's above
you is a [__] dick
i'm not mean like a dick like he just
has like a different
attitude to what you are thinking this
job is
and your first reaction is my first
reaction
we'll quit we'll quit that's it we'll
quit i'm looking for another [__] job
i don't need
a guy i'm working with to be a dick or a
boss of mine to be a dick we've all
gotten through this
but in time you [__] you know you
could either do what
joey diaz did for years and quit
or get to know what makes this person
tick
you know when i was younger i had no
disrespe i had no respect
and i didn't uh a job to me was
something i did just to make money i
didn't really give a [__] about you
i didn't give a [__] about your time
clock i didn't give a [__] with your
business burned
it was bad enough that i had to be here
you know what i'm saying that shitty
young
attitude you get when you're young this
is bad enough i got to be here
now i got to deal with this guy he's 10
maybe 15 years older than you
and he's kind of a dick but you don't
understand the dick that he is it's not
like he calls you names or
joe you're a fat [__] you're lazy i'm
not lazy i've always worked hard
it's just he had this air of attitude to
him
and it takes a while and
one day you know maybe eight months in
when you are ready to quit
and you want to [__] out like you do on
everything like me
you know something happens
the switch goes off and you say you know
what
if i can't beat them i join them
and something happens and next thing you
know
on a level of your performance as an
employee
you take it from one level to the next
because this guy kinda
took you under his wing but not really
and he was brutally honest with you
but we and when i say you i'm
including myself joey in this we were
too
[__] jerk offish to understand what
that person was actually trying to do to
me
and i've had i mean ten situation
electric
the guy was a dick to me at first and
next thing you know
i'm doing houses by myself he's trusting
me
to wire houses by myself i'm doing
comedy i'm doing comedy i'm doing
electric i was electric three months and
i'm already a residential wyoming he's
letting me do this
even though i had a problem with this
yes i had a problem with the main
supervisor
who i ended up beating up with a stick
and he had to leave town
that's a complete different story that
was practice for something else i was
doing
but the guy i was banging heads with
taught me how to be a [__]
electrician like he took me and he
this is how it needs to be done and you
got to cut it this way even though you
don't like it
you know sometimes we let our own
laziness and our own
kind of thing get into listen it's done
it there's a right way and there's a
wrong way to doing it
you could do it the wrong way and you're
gonna have to go back and or you could
do it the right way
okay so it happened to me with economics
when i was going to the university of
colorado i could not put economics
together
i applied for a tutor because i got two
free hours a week per class for tutoring
being part of the ceo od whatever it was
ceop
uh program which is basically if you're
latino or minority
you go in there you breathe and they
give you a c plus which
does nothing for the minority either but
i did it because they gave me money or
whatever
but i applied for this
um tutor
and his name you ready his name was
muhammad zabib when i got the [__]
note that you know muhammad's abeep now
i had really never
had contact with uh somebody from arab
or wherever he was from
egypt whatever all i knew was his name
was muhammad zabib
and i felt uncomfortable you know it's
19 [__]
uh 87 guys you know give me a [__]
break
i'm 27 years old or something
i'm a [__] idiot 24 something like
that i'm a [__] idiot
and i get this guy to help me and the
first six
[__] things it just didn't work out
for me with him like
i didn't really think i liked him
whatever i wasn't prejudiced i just
didn't know
where he was coming from and guess what
i got a [__] b on my test and i
[__] sucked the guy's dick
you know what i'm saying i didn't suck
his dick but i got a b
i was getting [__] c's and all of a
sudden this guy gets me a b
[__] plus with his help and his
kindness i think it was macroeconomics i
don't remember was just a class i was
having problems with
and he lifted me and after that i would
eat lunch with him
we would meet once a week i applied for
him to be like my [__]
uh my like uh whatever attache
whatever at the school another because
they wanted you to have another minority
to show you around i said i wanted him
and you know
it's just the way it is in life that we
go into something sometimes
and we don't know and we we we feel like
quitting or
this isn't for me or we feel like giving
up and
you know there's always that one person
in your life and i've been fortunate
enough
to have 50 of those people in my life
that's why i'm here
when i went to sell cars i [__]
didn't like it
there's a guy jim handy you know
everything happens for a reason
jim handy sat me down he goes what's the
problem i i
finally you know overcame my [__]
and i let him know what's going on he
goes all right we're going to start
simple
we're going to start with how many cars
do you want to sell a month i want to
sell 10 cars a month okay
how do you need to do that you need to
talk to four people a day
you need to send letters you need to
make calls you know
and even though i didn't like this
program guess what
when i started doing this program i
became successful
i went from you know being an average
car salesman
to being a monster [__] car salesman
and retaining gross and adding value to
the product i was selling
i learned so much from him so i never
really
didn't like jim i just thought he was
unconventional to me and that's
what we think when we see somebody
successful that's doing something
the right way and we're doing something
half-assed
we never want somebody to tell us that
we're spinning our wheels or doing
something half-assed god forbid
god forbid somebody come up to you and
go hey you're spinning your wheels
people like me can never come up to you
and say you're spinning your wheels
i'm sure a lot of you people think maybe
joey's spinning his [__] wheels no
i'm not
trust me i'm telling you i spammed my
wheels for [__] years
then i got into comedy comedy was a
complete different [__] thing
when i got into comedy in february 1st
of 1991 i went in there as a doorman
i kept my mouth shut and i watched
i spoke when i was spoken to and my
opinion
didn't mean dick and i knew that going
in i knew nothing about comedy
i took a three-hour stand-up comedy
class
and i [__] uh was a doorman
if the comic would talk to me you know
hey i want to come out to this song or
whatever
we would become friendly and uh
they would ask questions and i'd say
yeah i'm aspiring to be a comic
is there any advice you could give me
and you know 50
of them made stupid [__] comments to
me
20 percent were like good luck guy and
the other 30 were kind of helpful which
is really nice but that's the
that's what you have out there that's
what you have out there helping you
that's why you never know what direction
to go to you know and i'm sure it's the
same thing with [__] musicians
you know you show up to your first open
mic there's going to be a guy that says
you suck
you know what he's going to give you all
the reasons why you don't want to get
into the music business
because he didn't do it right because he
didn't do it right he's going to tell
you
he's going to come and [__] on your
[__] hat and tell you why not to do
it
so you know i had jim handy
and then i got into stand-up comedy and
the first guy that
spoke to me in stand-up comedy was a cat
named jimmy bait the little mexican dude
still out there just up opened up the
carlos couple nights ago
and pueblo you know her him and i were
neck and neck he got me into the game he
[__] took me to different shows he
forced me to go up on stage
i mean he did a lot of things i'm very
thankful for jimmy
till today i still talked to him on a
weekly
you know buy [__] monthly uh
thing but he was one of my first mentors
in comedy then i had andy payton who
helped me when i say
uh when i say mentors
i don't want you guys to think you know
what really bothered me
about my last couple years in l.a doing
the podcast was
people thought i could save their lives
like i could change their lives
if i come on your podcast i could sell
more tickets that
if i go on rogan's podcast i'll be an
international star
no you won't i got bad news for you no
you won't
it's everything that you're doing around
the joey diaz or the joe rogan or the
marc maron or the billboard podcast
that's making it work i don't want you
to ever think that you're sitting at
home
jerking off talking [__] on the phone
you're going to stroll over do a podcast
and your life is going to change if
that's what you really think
you know get out of this [__]
business get out of this business get
out of every [__] business
because you're wrong you take people and
you learn from them
and you don't ask you don't ask
you know it's not like you ask so my
first real mentor in standup was a guy
named todd jordan
who would have had a conversation with
friday and i had a great conversation
he didn't even know i hadn't moved to
jersey and then he sent me an email
after the conversation he goes i'm
really proud about what you did
he goes you were a good friend to
yourself you got out of la
and now you want to raise your family
because i saw the video you put up
of your daughter in softball he goes for
some reason i thought it was california
but now i make it made me like even more
because you didn't get caught up in the
[__] i go no
when it was over it was time to go but
he was my first mentor in the game
and and along the way then i went on
triple runs and stuff like that
and they were all negative headliners
that they're talking you out of [__]
not doing comedy and telling you why it
sucked and why the game sucks and
how mitsy sucks and this one sucked you
know they're just negative people i
didn't listen
i just thought that i i knew there was
something else out there
and in my mind at that time i thought
i was going to offer something different
you know that's all i want to do
was offer something different i get to
see adam
you know and uh i got i meet josh wolfe
and i meet
brodie and i meet doug stanhope and i
meet mitch hedberg
and again i didn't look at them as
mentors i looked at them as colleagues
there was no jealousy there was nothing
involved we just ended up doing comedy
i did have a mentor up there and his
name was carl wolmenhoven
he ran the open mic on mondays and
tuesdays
and when you got off stage he would
never critique you
he would say things to you to make your
act better
do you understand me so that's something
a lot of people
cannot handle is for somebody to tell
you how to make your life better again
we're going back to your job that job
that you have at the printing place
when you're cutting [__] whatever and
the guy comes over and he goes one thing
you're doing it great but can you do a
little and all of a sudden you take an
attitude
in our minds we're like i was doing you
know i was doing it right the first time
you didn't
trust me he said that to you for a
reason he's not saying that to you
to bust your balls or whatever you know
when somebody's [__] with you
but you know when somebody's trying to
tell you something
to make you better there's a big [__]
difference it's a big [__] difference
okay so
up in seattle i had called womanhoven
who was great he was great to me he was
great to josh wolf if you talk to josh
wolfe
a [__] brody we do a seance for brody
from the [__] past
i'm thinking of doing the seance for
broly just to hear your ouija board
positiveness
whatever the [__] he's saying uh
and you asked brody from the death he'll
tell you
none of us would have got to la without
carl womenhoven
he just made little adjustments and then
what he did was he brought his best
friend rick dukeman
who would come in another [__]
tremendous comment and a
tremendous individual to come in and
tweak us from time to time
and talk to us about l.a so when i moved
to l.a
my mentor right there was rick dukeman
i called rick every three or four days
his wife would help me with [__]
questions i had about the business just
i was just getting started
i really had nobody to [__] bounce
off i didn't know rogan i didn't know
anybody
once i became a regular at the store
then i met joe rogan and at first it was
you know he didn't smoke pilot then he
was on news radio
he was very uh rough you know and tumble
um he saw something in me and we became
friends we would
walk the pink dot and get sandwiches and
one day i asked him out right if i could
come watch the taping of news radio
he gave me his number and he goes call
me i called him he called me right back
i was living in the valley
i remember i went to see news radio and
i was blown away and and
the rest was history but that time the
comedy store
it wasn't the best times of the comedy
store when i arrived to the comedy store
in february of 97
it wasn't a good time up there they
weren't selling t seats
it was a ship run by the inmates you
know
there was no management there was
nothing mitzi sure was there she'd come
down once or twice a week
one of my all-time favorite talent
coordinators of all time
scott day was there he was very good to
me very honest with me
and i started doing spots at the store
i'm doing spots at the store i'm doing
spots at the store
you know you get to the store and you
think that you're hot [__]
and all of a sudden your first spot is
at 12 45 at night
and is that a beating on your [__]
ego
but you do what you need to do and you
[__] move on with it okay this one on
for maybe four or five [__] months 12
1 a.m then you move up to 12 30.
okay oh [__]
i'm making things happen i'm at 12 30
now you know what i'm saying
and then goes a couple couple months and
i go up to 12 15. now i'm making [__]
progress but there was only a problem
that the man that went up at 12 o'clock
every
night i did not
know he was even at the store when i was
living in seattle
in 1995 i
had already watched all the rodney
specials i had watched delirious back
and forth i studied it
i studied andrew nice clay i studied the
day that
comedy died i mean i just i
was a [__] student of the game okay
you know
sort of now with the guitar you know i
every night i come in here
i do my little practicing that my my
coach gives me
and then i'll put an album on and it'll
be a disaster
but at least i'm learning different
sounds and whatever you know and that's
the most important thing
you know and i knew this i knew this i
i wanted to be a comic more than
anything in the world
i didn't want to be a comedian i didn't
want to be a criminal anymore
i didn't want to be an addict i really
really thought the comedy would [__]
save me
so when mitzi sure made me a regular i
did everything i could
to be there learn and [__] absorb
and just i was such
i was so grateful that she made me a
regular i cannot describe to you
how i wanted to repay her it was like my
mother how my mother wanted her
my mother wanted to repay this country
for taking her
by throwing me into the army my mother
was willing to throw me into war
to to be to pay back her debt to the
united states of america for taking her
in
after that [__] went down in cuba that
that was her
state of mind at the time my state of
mind was
mitzi shaw let me in here i have to
[__] do something with this
i cannot go back to colorado a loser i
cannot go back to jersey
a loser i'm going to give it everything
i can
but then i bumped into a guy by the name
of dom herrera
and tom herrera was a [__] star
dom herrera was a [__]
natural philly comic you know
and i learned of him watching the rodney
dangerfield specials and i loved him and
i
i'll never forget that one night i had
to follow don herrera
in the main room and i got down there
early i watched him
i went up to him afterwards how you
doing before he went up how you doing mr
iraq i'm going up
after you and he gave me like a look how
any comic would that's just the way
comics are it's a psychological thing
he looked at me uh yeah whatever kid
whatever
what's your name joe d is a another
that's what we need another spanish
person in comedy and i'm saying we don't
have enough paul retriggers
whatever they just make little [__]
jokes you know so
i followed [__] him i went up there
was i cocky not really i just
i ate a bag of dicks you know
and he sat back there and loved every
minute of it
and the following saturday i went up
there again
and i ate another bag of dicks and then
i went and i did the biggest mistake a
man could do
i went and complained to mitzi i didn't
complain
i'm not a [__] like some people i one
told mitzi
the truth that i was having a hard time
following don morera
it was making me feel uncomfortable and
i was ruining the audience and i was
walking the audience i went up there and
was honest with her even though she goes
to me good
i'll put you back up there again next
week and the week after that
come back and tell me when you're having
a good time but until then you're going
to follow don myra to the debt
i was like [__] you don't know what it's
like to get in your car
and to [__] how would you like it if
i called you up and said hey i'm coming
over to pick you up
we're going to shoot you today you know
what i'm saying like
but better yet you have to drive
yourself like we're not even sending an
uber for you
you're gonna have to drive yourself to
come to my house i'm gonna put you in
the back i'm gonna give you a last
request
a cigarette and i'm gonna shoot you in
the [__] head how's that seem you
know that's what it got to be like on
saturday night
i would drive down there just shaking my
head like i'm gonna follow don marrero
but
that was saturday nights okay
something started happening during the
week now during the week you had andrew
who came in
and you had eddie griffin who came in
and
you know i learned a lot from eddie
and i learned a lot from watching andrew
i mean they were both geniuses in their
own way
i'm still fans and friends with both of
them
when i was in seattle
i can't remember what the comic's name
was and this is why i'm hesitant to tell
the story because i do not remember his
name
he was african-american it's gonna come
to me
and we got a gig together one night
and when i got in the car he was
listening to an african-american comic
and you know we got in the car how are
you doing what's up this is going to be
great we're going to yakima
washington the palm springs of you know
uh washington it was like a three-hour
drive i'm not sure
and it was me and clint and we smoked a
joint and uh
that was his name flint i think pops
right back in me and him smoked the
joint he was the headliner i was the
feature and we were giggling at this
[__] guy
and i just played the bit uh for mike
when he came here
the album was called race
and the the guy had the cassette i think
with a cd
and the cd was a black guy with his with
a gun in his hand
with two racers like on positions
getting ready to run i laughed at that
alone and
he was talking about you know white
people and what white people do and
scissor hands and
[__] that uh white man can't jump
they don't need to they own the team
he goes right now there's a black guy
there's a white guy in the bank
going man i got [__] jumping up and
down for me you know like just
no disrespect to anybody i'm just saying
what the man said on the
on the album and you know you just laugh
your [__] ass off at this [__]
and it's like it was like reverse racism
in a way
he was just goofing on white people you
know
so i listened to the album i asked him
what the name it was or
where i could get it and dawg i bought
that [__] album and i listened to
that [__]
every day i knew it backwards and
[__] forwards and i laughed
it was the first album that took me away
from the day the
laughter died i think but i i you got to
remind me you got to refresh me
there's been a lot of drugs a lot of
trauma a lot of heartache
you gotta so it was the first time like
he you know like you get stuck listening
to leads up and two legs up on two legs
up on two
even though all your friends are telling
you slipknot is great
[__] this band is great you're like
[__] it i'm gonna stick it out with
leads up on two legs up on two legs up
on two
and lost out of nowhere one day you put
the beach brothers on
you know what so what's this guys round
round turn around i turn around
yeah yeah all that [__] so you went from
that extreme even though your friends
are telling you to listen to slipknot
and everything
you turned around and went to [__]
this other band well anyway
so i take this [__] cd and i listen
to it
on every road trip i think he covers the
oj trial in there
he covers the beginning of the oj trial
i'm going to listen to it again this
week remember i had to do a lot of [__]
this week so i didn't really get a
chance to process it
so now i had a new problem saturday
nights i had to follow dom herrera which
was death
and now fridays monday through thursday
i had another dilemma i had to follow so
wait a second
so i'm into race i'm into this album
race i
i don't know if these if i had access to
the internet then
but i hunted down who this guy paul
mooney was
hunted him down he was a writer for
pryor he helped prior right
live on the sunset strip blah blah blah
the credits went on and on
he was homie the clown he wrote the
sketches for a living color
he wrote for the richard pryor show the
original one in the 70s
and just all this [__] but but wait a
second you're a writer
and you put this [__] cd out this is
[__] just great
you know i remember
the first night i walked into the comedy
store it was a monday night the first
person i saw was don barris
and i asked him if i could go up and he
goes to come back a little later he
didn't know who i was i dropped a couple
names
and the reason why i'm still a
sweetheart to don barris was why he put
me on stage that night
the first night i got that january 27th
on the store
when i was sitting there after i got a
soda the second person i saw was wheels
parisi who opened up to dice
for years and the third person i saw was
eddie griffin was there he was about to
go up on stage
and he was hanging out with the show
gonna harlem i don't know if you guys
ever saw that movie
the guy's name is like putak or tupac or
something like that
he was in the audience there was only
like eight people in the audience
and i sat there and i was blown away by
eddie griffin i was blown away by all
the comics i saw
and then at the end of the night don
barris put me up on stage and it was
great
um you know weeks later i became a
regular and
i think it was a month and you know i
started seeing gary shandling i started
seeing sarah silverman
i started seeing bill maher i started
seeing um
you know i would go up there with doug
stanhope at the time just to make
give me a little bit of confidence so
people wouldn't [__] with me i'm not
gonna lie to you
at that time nobody was [__] with
dirty doug and i was and i had his back
so if you did [__] with dirty dog it was
gonna be an ugly situation
i was still raw i still had my leather
jacket you know
not bueno and uh
you know doug was on the road and i
started going down there by myself and i
was a big boy
and one night i looked and there was
this guy that was holding the gun
at that cover and it was paul mooney in
the flesh
if you guys think i salivated all over
myself i didn't i complain i contained
my composure
and he was on at midnight and
i was on at 12 15. and
i was i wasn't scared i didn't think
about it i
did what any other young comic would do
and they're supposed to do
you're supposed to watch the guy that
goes up ahead of you
and that's exactly what i did i went in
the green room i sat in missy's chair
in those days there weren't no 80 people
at midnight
there was basically 14 people there and
six of them
eight of them were there to watch paul
mooney they were his friends or whatever
he didn't he didn't do 15 minutes he
went up then did a [__] hour
so i [__] you know i'm like what the
[__] i didn't say nothing to him
i'm a young comic he obviously he's got
juice he knows richard pryor and he did
all those things
i took my lumps and not only that when
he gets off the stage
eight people get up with him now i'm
down to six
so i gotta go up on stage and entertain
six [__] people
whoop-dee-doo that's your comedy career
that's why you moved out to l.a
huh that that's why so think about these
things guys these are the things you got
to think about
that yeah i'm going to la no it's not
six people six people what happened to
the people from abc
what happened to the people from nbc
that what happened to the people from
[__]
uh whatever records rhino records that
were gonna be there there was nobody
there
you know your dream of somebody's gonna
see you
i was up there on stage for six people
and every night i would leave their
[__] more and more depressed
and i remember one night i actually went
up to brian holtzman and i'm like
this sucks and he goes dog i just saw
you destroy six people
what do you mean this sucks like i've
been doing this for a year following
[__] moony or six months at the time
this sucks well i'm not getting anywhere
he's like you're following a legend
you're getting to watch this guy
and then you're going up there yeah but
i can't even try my new jokes
because there's six people again
you learn how to [__] and uh what's
what's a quarterback do like the line of
scrimmage when he changes to play
you got to call an audible in your life
sometimes you got to call an audible
i i sat there i'm not going to lie to
you guys i could sit here and tell you a
bunch of [__] oh
i sat back there for three months and
actually hated him
because he would make me [__] do this
every night
for [__] uh you know six months
you know what that's like when you have
a [__] dream and somebody's in the
way of your [__] dream every night
and he goes up there
but so finally something something
brought back to you joe diaz and i go
you know what
if i can't beat him i'm gonna join this
[__]
one thing i didn't notice in those three
months which was that he was
a tremendous comedian a tremendous
comedian i
and if you sit here make me go joey
describe to me
how he was a tremendous comedian
he had no fear he tackled subjects
you know he would go on stage and go
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] he goes i love saying the
word [__] it makes my teeth white
you know he goes there's a there's a he
goes
he goes i'm gonna keep saying [__]
until a white guy gets up and calls
9-1-1 and saying
hello la police there's a [__] on
stage and he won't stop saying [__]
and i would die a laughter at that
stupid joke
and then one night he said he knew
madonna when she was madiana
he goes i knew madonna i know that
little [__] when she was manana or
something like that
and i started watching what he was doing
to the audience
so instead of watching him i started
watching the audience
and i would go wow you know carla beau
is one thing you know
[__] you know this comic that's
working dom
herrera is something else and joe rogan
was up there doing his [__] thing at
that time and he was ripping it you know
all these comics were doing that thing
but what paul mooney was doing
was a different level he was breaking
barriers jack
he was going up there and talking [__]
and making you feel
uncomfortable and comfortable at the
same time
that's a gift that's not a knock knock
joke you dumb [__]
he was well planned and he was he was a
fighter up on stage he would throw
jabs at you to see how you would react
to them how you would move
and once he found that he could keep
punching you in that nose and that
target
he was relentless he kept punching you
in that nose and that target
and then he would switch it up and he
hit you with two body shots
to [__] let you get your breath back
and then he'd start
throwing that he would start throwing
that cross [__] right hand
breaking your [__] nose it was
something
you cannot you know and comedy is is is
is this up and down you know he had it
all combined and i'm sure if he talked
to bill burr
i'm sure you talked to any of the comics
that were there at that time
watching paul mooney i mean dawg i saw
him walking with elizabeth [__]
taylor one night this was a black man
an african-american man that went up
there and
[__] did not
talk bad about white people he just let
him know how they were [__] up to the
point where they were even laughing at
themselves
edward scissorhand you know he was just
saying [__]
but i took to that and one night
actually went to him like a man like oh
paul i've been watching you for a long
time man
and i'm learning a lot from you you know
this is [__] great and he was
he would call me a cuban [__] he would
he would say look who it is the cuban
[__] all you cubans and [__] anyway i
mean
he was just saying [__] to me that was
[__] you know
that would make me like it wasn't
getting me mad at all
it was he was saying it out of love
and he loved joe he would always goof on
joe too he would tell
joe that he was a negative he was
sicilian because you're nothing but a
[__] too
you and your cuban little chubby friend
and stuff he would say things to us and
and it became to the point where i would
not miss
any of his performances because i always
knew i would take something from it
he taught me the gift of going up there
and we talked about this last week on
the podcast
going up there standing up listen if
you're going to tell a joke
and you're going to tell it this way
with your body
not behind the joke it's not going to
work the audience sniffs that
you got to go up there plant your feet
commit yourself
and [__] yell out to the audience and
not let them worry about what the [__]
they're thinking
that's why this can't we're letting an
outside individual come in and try to
cancel us
no my work is the from the reaction of
the audience
that's who could cancel me that's who
could actually say something to me
nobody else can just that [__]
audience
and that's what i took from paul mooney
i took something from everybody i'm not
a joke thief i'm not a thief
but i took something from andrew dice
clay i took a little bit from [__]
joe rogan you see it in me
you definitely i tried to mimic burr
he's [__] tough to
to mimic i like sometimes marc maron's
delivery is very deadpan
but one guy that i went after that i
really
mimicked a lot and if and i'll show you
even with the storytellers
was a lot of moony stuff it wasn't
thievery i didn't steal his material
i stole his train of thought
and how he would attack the audience
that's what i stole from him and that's
what i took from a lot of other comics
but nobody being more than paul mooney
paul mooney did not go up there to hold
back paul mooney went out there to fire
at you
and then explained to you in an
intelligent manner
not like me i'm a dummy why he thought
that way
so yes he made you feel uncomfortable
for two minutes but then for eight
minutes he made you agree
and even if you were white at the end
you go you know what
i'm starting to hate honkies myself and
[__] that's how he would do it
but not in the [__] not the way it's
done today
he wasn't up there bashing white people
no
he was just talking about our
in our stupidity things are
the things we do that were kind of
[__] stupid
and because of that he became my mentor
not because he wrote jokes for me did i
post a picture of him and me up
no we weren't that type of friends we
were other type of friends
then he found out i was dating my wife
my wife was a waitress at the store
and he would give her [__] about the
cuban i don't know what the [__] he's
seen that cuban
he's a bad [__] comic but he
ain't a good looking man at all i mean
he would always
and i remember one day and he was he was
gay
he was gay and he dated white guys so
that on stage was an act and he loved
the track
i i can't tell you how many times i saw
him at hollywood park
and he would yell at me cuba you know
you know another time me and my wife
were walking on sunset
and laurel canyon we were there's a
sushi place
a coffee place or a sushi place inside
and we were walking
and i saw he had a white convertible
and i saw the convertible see me and he
didn't want me to see me and he made a
huge u-turn on sunset
and he yelled cuba
get your ass home they're killing [__]
out here these days
like that that's the [__] he would say
to me you know
but uh
i asked him once if i went to miami
to do the show and
i would go to the improv a lot i would
go to miami improv every six weeks
because i was cuban
and they would request me as a feature
act i would stay down there for two or
three weeks
and feature for headliners then it got
to the point that there was a rumor
going around
that joe diaz was the only feature that
brought his own headliner with him
so i actually contacted the improv and i
go listen man
i had a i had a support i had a guy
named john x
great comedy book a great [__]
guy he ran the dc improv he quit
he moved on if anybody knows how to get
ahold of john x
please have him hit me up because i'm he
was in dc and
uh he was good friends with paul mooney
he felt the same thing i felt about paul
mooney
so when i called robert hartman's office
who booked the improv i said
i think you guys should really book paul
mooney
you know there was just a couple clubs
booking them new york would book them at
night
at midnight at caroline's and
i got them into miami i finally talked
um joe chadwick who was the manager in
miami to speak
to john x in dc and they gave him a rate
they didn't give him a lot of money you
know he was paul mooney they tried to
[__] with him
let me tell you something paul went down
there and destroyed those miamians
and he destroyed the cubans and i loved
it
it was the week of elian fernandez that
one gonzalez when defense went in and
got him
and he would open up with how you doing
cubans you [__] got your [__]
wake up call
you guys thought you were part of a
jewish community down here in
in miami hanging out with jews eating
bagels and look at you
they still come down and take your [__]
cubans were walking out
in the hand droves they were just not
accepting paul mooney me
i didn't give a [__] i was loving what
he was saying there was some brothers in
there and some african-americans older
see he drew an older african-american
crowd
and they were great and but the second
night i was there
listen at this time i was friends with
paul mooney i wasn't best friends with
him
i was friends with him i got him the
week at the improv
but on the other side of that guys
i was starting to rock i was starting to
rock hard when you follow paul mooney
for two years now
your confidence [__] you're showing up
with your dick up out i would just show
up with my dick out what [__]
you want
you know there was headliners that were
having a hard time following me
because of the confidence that paul
mooney was insane instilling in me
i was following paul mooney five [__]
nights a week and then domino on
saturday
what the [__] do you think was gonna
happen to you what do you think will
happen to a man when you put him in a
cage
for five [__] days six days and then
they will let me out in these mickey
mouse clubs
across the country these funny bones and
[__] and i would take their [__]
headliners and
wipe the stage with them and they would
all complain about me
you know what i didn't give a [__] see
at that time i wasn't a team player
my job was to go in there and be become
a headliner
so my job was to go in there and [__]
that [__] room up [__] the headliner
he would get off you can't say [__] you
can't improvise
you can't do this [__] you my job is to
destroy that [__] room
whether you like it or not listen my
advice to feature acts today is
you're part of a show you're there to
enhance the show not to knock this
[__] out of the box
but if you need to you know uncle joey
will always give you the green light
some headline that gives you [__] and
tells you you can't do some certain
material i expect you to go up there and
light your balls on fire so he can't
follow it
[__] him if he builds himself as a
headliner he's got to follow you
and that's what paul mooney taught me so
when i say that when i r.i.p
paul mooney on twitter the other day i
didn't rip him as a [__]
mentor who taught me how to write and
sat me down
and schooled me i learned from watching
him
but the ultimate gift if i have to tell
you
the three biggest things that happened
to me in my career one would have to be
the many saints in newark
one would have to be my meeting with joe
rogan
and the third thing best thing that have
happened in my career
was i was in miami one night
paul mooney was about to follow me
and i went up on stage and i went on a
[__]
rant that was don't ask me what i was
saying
don't ask it was classic joey diaz
it was just punches to your face
people i would not let you [__]
breathe at that point
i had made kevin mini quit i had made a
couple comics in miami go i don't want
to follow you i want to switch it
with you i was up there [__] rocking
guys and you know i'm not big i'm
blowing my own horn
it's 2002 2003. i was becoming a
dangerous man out there and nobody was
giving me love
which was making me angrier and i was
going for it at one point i looked over
to the side
and i saw a paul mooney with the door
open
and he was yelling
he was yelling at the bartenders and
there was a manager there
and in my mind i'm like i better wrap it
up because paul mooney
is getting angry at my language he's
getting angry at what i'm doing up here
i just lost a friend i i he's never
going to work with me again
at that time i was causing so much habit
in miami
that the hate was starting to grow for
joey diaz as the headliner
like those little bee headliners they
caught they couldn't cover it
they couldn't cover the spread and i'm
here to tell you the truth
i saw paul money doing that and i was
brokenhearted
i thought that he had turned on me i
thought that he was
yelling at the staff to come and give me
the light to get me off the stage
i got off the stage i gave him
a [__] beautiful introduction because
i thought i was going to get fired
i didn't you know i i shook his hand i
hugged him and i said that the great
paul mooney
you know uh [__] i gave his credits
at the time and
i got upstage and i remember being down
i went into the bathroom and i pissed
and
i went to the bar and i go so am i fired
and they were like what are you talking
about
and i go when i was up on stage
i saw paul mooney [__] yelling and
screaming you know i don't know
if i did something wrong if i was
cursing too much of him like my material
and joe chadwick came home and he's like
no
he was here insulting us telling us how
much the improv
suck that that right there is the
product of the comedy store
that is the [__] savagery that mitzi
made and he was just blowing [__] my
you know he was just saying things to
them about me like you see that
that's what a comic really is you see
that he has no fear
you see that that [__] is a
savage and he's gonna do something with
his life someday
you see and he was just telling them
like you [__] improv suck
he hated bud friedman he hated all those
people
but he needed work he was getting old he
was 58 at the time this you know
he died this week he was 70 something he
was up there
just giving me praises and when i walked
off the stage
that when he walked off the stage that
night i went up to him and said what was
that about he goes i am so [__] proud
of you
he goes you have become he goes i never
saw you do that at the store i go
because [__] i gotta follow you
in front of six [__] people i go
that's
what you did for me man that's the
confidence i remember that the week
before
i was like in uh the funny bone
and
in mishawaka right under misha walker is
with notre dame
and i was working with this weak ass
[__] comic he's on
ships now i threw a beating on him
as a guest spot that the feature and the
[__] headliner crumbled at those days
i would take my comedy store lineups
with me
on the road in those days i had a
girlfriend in michigan when i would stay
with her
i would call clubs and go can i do a
guess and now we never heard of you
give me your fax number [__] and
i would send them my fax enough
i would send them the cred the [__]
uh the call sheets from the lineup and
they would say
paul mooney joe diaz i follow paul
mooney on a nightly basis
i can't do a guest body you're [__]
dumping there we go all right
come on down so
[__] uh you know i got to spend those
five days with paul mooney
and it was just me and him and he got to
watch me and
you know he i think i
went off course one night and i told the
story
like a little story and he said that
that night when i got off he goes
that little story captivated me
he goes maybe you should try telling
more stories on stage and i go nah
nobody wants to hear my stories
but uh we went back to la you know
we were still friends every night we
goof around cuba
this that this and that and this and
then in 2000
uh he did me a uh a big fan of he called
me he goes hey
i'm stuck and i forgot to book a feature
for new york
do you mind opening for me at caroline's
and right there on the phone i could
feel
the [__] and the [__] come out of my dick
and then i just pissed myself that
i was opening up for paul mooney at
caroline's and it was just four shows
no it was two shows it was two midnight
shows on a friday night
and i'll never forget that one night i
walked off the stage and i was sitting
on the side and i saw lori metcalf i
don't know if you guys
i don't even know if i'm saying her
right she was she played uh
the sister and league of her own to gina
davis
she was working broadway and she was
really good friends with paul mooney
and she came to watch paul and i was
maybe
you know i was in awe of her i was in
awe
there were there were actors in the
audience here to watch paul mooney
and i'll never forget that i [__]
looked over at her and she was
saying his material as he was saying as
he was saying and i'm like
ain't this about a [__] and then
we all went back to la
and john x took him on as a manager
and he
gave an extend a pretty extensive tour
schedule
you know at least paul mooney at the end
was going to go out like a gentleman
because nobody had given them respect
all those years you know they looked at
him as priors boy
i never looked at him like that i hate
when people look at
people as somebody else's boys no we all
have to serve an apprenticeship
lee served an apprenticeship now lee's
doing what he's doing
i served an apprenticeship for rogan now
i'm doing what i'm doing
don't ever be ashamed to serve an
apprenticeship
i don't want you to kiss somebody's ass
or have your nose up somebody's ass
but a mentor comes in a lot of ways
a mentor comes in a lot of ways
and for me listen
when i heard he died i was a little
upset i thought about our times together
and uh i'm grateful i'm grateful that he
was one of the guys
when you see me doing my thing on stage
yelling and going crazy and
eating ass and it was it was
inspired by paul mooney with paul mooney
gave me he gave me a gift
he gave he let me watch him learn and
study from him
so from now on when somebody's kind of
being weird to you or whatever
step back look back and see what this
guy's really trying to do
don't hate on him try to learn from him
to make you better
and to lift you up to be a better person
that's enough about paul mooney before i
wrap it up this week i got to talk to
you about something
it's a beautiful monday to be alive this
weekend memorial day weekend you're back
out
i guess coverts done i got on the plane
and uh
i'm here so unless by wednesday i'm not
back then i don't know i have [__]
covert
i had a free [__] uh i got an email a
few weeks ago from jetblue
that i was gonna lose my money if i
didn't use it
so i booked a couple vacations for my
wife but what i wanted to do first was
i had to go to la because i'm
putting together a strain of joey diaz
weed for the ice cream shop
it's going to be like 90 [__] percent
your eyeballs are going to blow out of
your [__] head
so i wanted to i needed to do that
uh when i got here to do the [__]
surgery
i got sent to a heart doctor and he
broke my balls and he made me do all
these tests
and then he didn't want to give me the
the medication i was getting
in la he wanted me to go through another
battery a test for the last three weeks
and i go [__] you i called my doctor in
l.a my doctor goes come out
i'll do an ekg i'll do it in my office
and i'll prescribe whatever the [__] you
need so i put that down
and then last the last two weeks i've
been having a hard time
something was bothering me on the inside
of my mouth and i kept waking up every
morning this morning spitting blood
and i was using the wrong um false
floss so two one day i had to go
i just made an appointment at a dentist
over here
and he told me that the lady who had
whoever had done the work for me
originally
[__] uh they had to do something over
here so i said [__] it
i'm going to l.a i'm going to see the
doctor i'm going to see the wheat store
i might as well see dr sherry my girl
while i'm there
so i i said listen my schedule's going
to be i i got a plane ticket
i left thursday morning at 5 45
the driver picked me up i got a 7 30
flight i landed in that lane at 7
30. my plans for those three things
i was going to definitely go to dinner
with dean delray
and i didn't know what i was going to do
at night because the time difference
remember 9 30 l.a time is midnight
new york time and i'm already on the new
york times so i said [__] it
papa's getting tired yeah papa's gonna
be getting tired i don't know about
and once i got there guys
i knew i didn't want to be there like i
knew why i left
when i'm done with something i'm [__]
done with something
so i uh did the three things i had to do
i got back to my hotel room around three
o'clock
i called dean delray um kate couldn't
meet me because she had a
gig at 8 30 and she had something to do
too for
i felt really bad because she felt bad
but like okay i just dropped this on you
this is what's wrong with people people
think that just because they flying to
town
people got to drop what they're doing
now i knew you were busy i didn't want
to make a big announcement
and to be honest here the real reason
why i went to la
was to small the circle on a guy there's
a guy that [__] with me
for the last three years and now we're
gonna get our [__] day in the sand
so i went this to to to [__] reel in
the circle on him a little bit just so
he knows he's
[__] running things tighten the noose
you know what i'm saying
so i wanted him to know i was going
there
so now i got him sleeping thinking why
was he here for one day
but when i got back to my hotel room at
four
i just knew i couldn't stay in l.a that
night
i was like i'm not spending my [__]
night in l.a
i called every [__] airline i
couldn't get back
it was terrible no southwest
jet blue wasn't flying out of burbank no
more or there's only two flights a day
two direct flights a day to l.a so i'm
like what the [__] am i gonna do
and i went in my wallet and i found an
old [__] mosaic card that's like the
high level
people at jetblue and i called the
number and i told him the truth i said i
gotta get the [__] outta here lady goes
listen
you're not gonna believe this a ticket
just opened up in 1a i go
[__] it put me on it so i was basically
i got that lay at 10 30 in the morning
and i was back on a plane thursday night
at 9 20. i landed five [__] 0-5
my boy alex was there he gave me a ride
home i got home by 605
and uh i did it
and i didn't do it for the [__] to be
honest here i could have
done a zoom call with the guy for the
reefer the doctor would have probably
sent me the prescription and i could
have gone to a different dentist here
the real reason why i do it did it was
to eliminate my fear
i wanted to just i gotta take this [__]
in little strides man
this whole pandemic thing took me for a
[__] while
i'm getting better you can see i'm
getting better i'm looking better
still no weed if i don't smoke by
tomorrow night it'll be
[__] three no three weeks already
three [__] weeks already um
i don't know if i look any different i'm
still ugly as [__]
uh i've lost some weight and it's not
like i'm running marathons i can't tell
you my knee's still
getting healed but i'm happy i'm doing
this i'm happy i'm doing this
when i come back i get nice and [__]
stoned
what i am going to do is the first time
i do smoke i am going to smoke for you
guys because
i want you guys to see what i used to do
to lee
if you don't think when i take that
first hit i'm gonna do it to you my
eyeballs are gonna fly out and i'm gonna
drool all over myself
and [__] that's gonna happen so paybacks
are a [__]
thank you for watching have a great
[__] monday morning
i know that happy is this week after
tomorrow your heads are going to be up
your ass
thinking about memorial day weekend uh
what's what color is the tablecloth it's
going to be you know
are we using ranch therefore are we
going with the traditional onion you
know all that [__] how many hot dogs
yeah so you guys are going to be brain
dead but anyway i wanted to catch you
today
uh rest in peace paul mooney thank you
very much guys for watching
and uh we'll be back wednesday tip top
magoo
love you [__] have a great day
thank you for watching
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening today and you know who brought
this show together for you today
manscaped with a public service
announcement
it's finally here the lawnmower 4.0
the lawnmower 4.0 has the same advanced
ceramic blade
and skin safe technology you know and
love
plus the 4.0 lets you set the length of
your own trim
that is [__] tremendous because you
could play around with your dick a
little bit you know what i'm saying
you could shave the even when you were a
kid you got hair on the outside like
bozo the clown
but the middle was open you could
[__] shave the top
let the sides fill in and do a comb over
for your dick
they don't know you listen you gotta
have a sense of humor anyway
now and they also have a spotlight
that's even better with the on and off
switch
and the 4000k led light and they got a
travel lock
you could take your ball trimming show
on the road like i did i always bring
[__] manscape with me i got an extra
one in my little bag
and i bring it with me along with the
crop exfoliator
and the crop gel get the lawn more and
more with the ultra
smooth [__] package let me tell
you what that has that has the crop
shaver
this isn't your average razor it's
smaller thicker with micro comb hair
and three position blades i'm also gonna
give you the crop exfoliator listen
no more you ever have like an itch and
you have like a little lump
that means one of your disgusting hairs
grew into another [__] pore
which makes an ingrown hair that's not
going to happen with the crop exfoliator
and i'm also going to throw you the crop
gel which features four essential oils
it's like a spa treatment for the
[__] helmet you understand me
you get out of there your dick is tip
top my goo and your nuts
sack looks better that's ever looked in
[__] years we're also going to throw
in the crop shaver like i said before
and if you want to get out there and
sling dick with three hands
it's memorial day weekend it's the
summer time you're going to be out there
every week
stay on top of your dick you want to
sling dick on the beach like they used
to in the movies
remember elvis at the beach how he slung
dick he had manscaped okay
so do yourself a favor if you want to
get out there and be like [__] elvis
get the ultra smooth package and the
lulma 4.0 today
salute the flag shave your nuts it's
going to be a beautiful
memorial day weekend but it starts with
you going to manscape.com
joey again manscape.com joey
again manscape.com joey and get 20
off with free worldwide shipping by
going to manscape.com
joey manscape use the right tools
for the job [__] i love you stay
black
have a great [__] week and i'll see
you guys
wednesday tip top [__] magoo
i love you guys
[Music]
there you go
so
[Music]
foreign
you